um Frank is the right person to do this
because for many reasons including the
fact that um he has this way of um you
know well first he he loves to give
whiteboard talks and secondly he can
take a as you know as it has been said
he can take one Slice worth of material
and stretch it out into a thought which
is very good for the starting of the
discussion okay
thanks so uh I would certainly like to
thank uh alista for all the whatever the
organizational kind of things it's to uh
to uh to be here also to of course the
organizer so thanks for uh um for
inviting all of us here and uh I'm sure
we will be able to kind of make some uh
this conference will be kind of uh uh
full of discussions and uh F fill its uh
promise so the only other conference
that I've been uh that uh is a bit
similar to this one was like in 2006 or
2007 in uh in Leiden and um I was also
giving the first talk there and uh
you're not going to say this no no I'm
not going to say this I'm not going to
say it so what happened is that I was I
was uh in the first row there was uh
Julia dorit and Barbara sitting and uh
and I made it I I could not make it was
my second slide okay so I had like
prepared 20 slides and they bombarded me
with questions one after the other one
and I it was impossible to kind of compl
I made it to my second slide and since
then I vot
that if Barbara and dor are sitting in
the audience I never prepared anything
anymore
um okay so uh so that's the reason that
IED I don't have slides I have anyway so
so what was the main theme back then in
uh in in lien of the of of the
conference so this was the very
beginning somehow there were lots of of
hardness results okay proving that uh
simulating Quantum spin systems is is is
is hard okay that that uh all was all
everything you could prove that
everything was was was was uh was QA so
uh so remember somehow the very nice
results like that that that on a 1D
chain somehow you have a local
hamiltonian and finding ground offf this
ISC me how this was one of the kind of
these these very very first results of
uh uh I I actually don't really remember
who all there were many kind of quarters
on this uh uh on this paper Barbara for
example had an also a paper where uh you
did it on a two- dimensional lce okay
you just have like a local H on cubits
on on a two dimensional lce finding the
ground set of that uh problem was uh was
also Q so there was like there was there
was like I see it l as that time was the
destructive period okay proving that
everything is impossible okay you cannot
so proving that things are uh are hard
so so after that and actually this
inspired quite a lot of of of of of of
more results like like proving that that
that density functional theory is hard
okay so in density functional Theory you
have like a functional that you have to
guess and what you could prove is using
these tools of qma you could prove that
if you can uh um um if if you would be
able to guess that functional that
people use in DFT this was the result
with with Norbert then uh um then you
could solve all problems in qma okay so
they were like um and representability
this was with Yi I think Yi was also
somewhere but um so that there's lots of
things so
and like I I kind of see rather the
analogy with um with rock bands okay a
rock band a very good rock band first
has a destructive period okay they uh uh
they kind of get rid of all the overhead
they kind of destruct everything and
then somehow after a while when they
mature uh so I guess actually Barbara
and dor have matur so they don't they're
not that nasty
anymore um um then somehow the next
stage is the constructive period okay
and I think this is what we have
witnessed like in the in the last years
okay like um and I think this is great
so the so uh so actually the it's not
always like that I think with with drug
bands actually prefer their destructive
periods okay I think like like Ein the
noon I don't know who knows this band
but this is the the prime example at
some point they really decided we have
been destructive enough now we have to
be constructive and then from then on
they were not good anymore but I think I
hope that somehow here with this field
this is completely different um okay so
so um the first kind of really
fantastic constructive result was uh uh
was the one of Matthew Hastings where he
proved that there's like an area low
that if you have a gapped Quantum many
body system hamiltonian Quantum spin
system in one dimension then somehow
this satisfies an area law okay this is
this is a very strong result okay it
shows that inde there was kind of uh um
well this is not enough yet to to to to
to this is not some phrasing it yet in
some the language of of computational
complexity but that's what what UMES and
uh and z and and many Coors can of did
in the in the last year so this is I
think is actually a fantastic result so
these are the kind of constructive
things that uh that show that actually
things that seem to be hard or actually
not that hard if you have some extra
conditions some extra rist so like like
like like a gap in in the system um
other kind of constructive things I
think uh it's not really kind of
computational complexity but what I uh
what I what I what I really like is kind
of these results that come from
entanglement Theory starting from
entanglement Theory you kind of with
somehow many people came up with some
some some some way of understanding
ground States and qu to many body wave
functions in terms of tenser networks
and uh and this led to somehow new novel
kind of ways of classifying phases of
matter okay I think this is very
constructive this is not constructive in
the sense of computational complexity
but but rather constructive in the case
of of of of physics it's really you
needed somehow these tools of
entanglement Theory before you could do
this and I think that's exactly kind of
the um somehow the um the the what what
what what what the team of this uh of
this Workshop to try to understand
somehow get some better insight into
these these things so uh not just
classifying phases also just defining
what does it really mean to have
topological Quantum order okay this is
um this is actually very very vague and
you can there's no order parameters
somehow there's some very strange things
but once you phrase the question in
terms of wave function and this was
again kind of of pioneer by by Matthew
Hastings it's actually possible to
Define what uh what what topological
order is okay you can really start
defining a state has topological order
okay without without without kind of
even needing some kind of hamiltonian or
whatever so there's so you need this
this this whole framework of of Quasi
altic Evolution for this that that mat
you developed and using this you can
actually start proving that a state has
topological order and uh so what this is
about it it happens that actually the
conditions for having a state with
topological order is very very similar
to the coms for having eror connecting
codes okay this is actually a fantastic
I think kind of merging of of of IDs
from different fields and these are kind
of prime examples of this and uh and
it's actually pretty subtle if you kind
of try to Define it you have to put the
epsilons and it's exactly in the
epsilons that the definition is like for
topological order you must have another
state that is kind of has all the same
local expectation values but
nevertheless somehow it's it's globally
remains orthogonal to it and the
difference between the topological
ordered State and non topological
ordered state is actually in kind of
saying what the eror is that you make
when when when you have your system and
we make it larger and somehow in the
case of of a topological code somehow of
topological order this kind of error
must scale exponentially small and if
it's only polom then we know that this
is actually not topological order okay
so so so it's really kind of putting
somehow these these these these these
Epsilon and Deltas there you need them
to Define physical concepts of of what
topological order is yes I'm you
challenge me too much though I have to
be nasty
now can you give a actually you give an
example maybe of this of
this um yes so see this so let me um so
what is the if you have if you have a
state or what are the kind of conditions
for so so let's see I I have a state
size zero and I would like to make the
claim that actually this is the ground
state of some local hon and things like
that but uh uh ands has topological
order it happens that uh under some
condition I will not write down all the
condition but somehow what you are
interested in is kind of looking at
um um kind of quantities like this okay
expectation values of local operators
and local means acting on L sides l a
block with the diameter L um and it
happens that for topological order you
want that this is like Delta i j times
some function of O local order that does
not depend on I or J this is just or you
can just put I if you want of course
because there's an i and J here um but
plus something that is exponentially
small and
L okay so what it means is that if I
have so so so think think about the code
okay so you have I have two different
kind of ground States okay so with
respect so so first of all if I is equal
to J somehow you cannot distinguish with
local operators in which ground States
you are okay this is exactly this Delta
i j the fact that this function doesn't
depend on I this is actually this is
this is this uh uh this is but I is
equal to J but also when I is different
than J then somehow there should not be
a local operator that allows you to move
from one from that state to that state
okay that's true then somehow you would
not have topological order so this is
exactly the condition for error
correcting codes actually if you so the
whole kind of thing is here in this fact
this condition that this has to be
exponentially small so in the toic code
this is actually exactly zero but for
General kind of systems this can be
exponentially small so suppose that we
would relax this and say maybe this good
enough that this is like a
poly 1 /
M okay and let's try to prove let's try
to check whether for example the St all
spins up has topological order okay
indeed somehow I can actually construct
a state orthogonal to this namely all
spins up and then one spins down and all
spins up and I take the superos over K
where this is like
theate position okay so you see that
actually that state is clearly AAL to
that one it has actually all the same
local expectations values because
locally you cannot you cannot
distinguish that state from that state
actually this is in in the in language
of of of mathematical physicist they
mathematical physicist would say that
this state is equal to that one here
okay because in the ter in the teric
limit okay because in the teric limit
there's no way you can distinguish that
state from that state with local
operators okay but uh but on a finite
system somehow what you see is that that
somehow there is some that this will
kind of be a poly instead of uh uh uh an
exponentially kind of small thing in the
length of your uh system so actually
this is not just the L this is there's
there's two length scales there's a size
of your system and there's the size of
the block and it's kind of the relation
I'm not so sure exactly what the the
right but this is what is going on and
and and see so you need really
exponential such polinomial otherwise
somehow this this doesn't work and uh if
this explanation is small then you can
really kind of use the whole formulism
of qu altic evolution or things I have
to really show that this is can really
useable so this is the kind
of things that so you see this is very
useful okay to have this this knowledge
of entanglement here Quantum information
to error correction this is exactly the
same language and you need this to
Define what topological orders another
thing that has been uh is that is that
satisfactory uh another thing that has
been extremely kind of uh uh successful
in in con matter physics so that people
have been interested in this is is
something that's called the anagement
Spectrum okay so they so at the end this
is nothing more than actually the the
Schmid uh the Schmid Spectrum okay so
the I values of your uh of your sty
Matrix so you have like a chain a chain
or whatever or two dimensional system
but in chain it's it's easier you kind
of cut it in two pieces you look at
somehow the reduced dity Matrix to the
left and um and it happens that for many
physical systems it is kind of
interesting or kind of relevant and this
is what how who kind of first proposes
to understand this as some kind of a
termal state okay because this is a
positive operator of course you there's
always a Honan that left is equal to
this okay it happens that indeed the
Spectrum the Schmid coefficients has
some meaning in terms of somehow this
this and out of this somehow people were
able to to really kind of distinguish
phases lots of there there's lots of
applications that physicists kind of
have com met physis from uh from from
from this relation okay this so I think
these are all examples of of U um so um
what
um they actually only looked at the I
values okay somehow what what this whole
framework of of of qu information and T
networks and so for can give you it's
also the I vectors it can really kind of
Iden so what you see is that somehow
this is like if this is a
two-dimensional system you would have
like a two dimensional spin system so
you have all your your spins that is R
left is typically kind of an exponential
of an quasi one dimensional kind of
honia okay this is exactly related to
this kind of area law or boundary the
because if you kind of cut your system
into two pieces you inde expect somehow
that it's only degrees of freedom along
the border that basically matter for
defining somehow what happens in this
left side okay they uh and so this is a
step further it's not just saying that
this is a r left they say actually you
can kind of identify a local
onedimensional hamiltonian that has
exactly the same Spectrum as this R left
okay but uh this is uh so this is uh
actually this is certainly much stronger
than saying that you have that you have
an area law and uh it happens that this
whole formalism of TX and networks
allows you to identify even these
degrees of freedom so they just looked
at the Spectrum but somehow you can
identify which degrees of freedom are
actually uh is this hiltonium this one
dimensional Honan acting on and in terms
of these T networks we got very excited
together with nor we got very excited
about this like two years ago because
you could you can really kind of do
these things uh very clearly if you kind
of use the right language uh for
describing uh this thing okay so um uh
so there's lots of there's clearly lots
and lots of kind of of of of of ideas of
of of quantum information Tang theory
that allowed somehow to that that that
proved very useful in uh uh in U matter
physics I think and there will be will
be much more somehow so so for example
recently there was a conference in Santa
Barbara with with had lots of quo field
the so people in quto field the also
like very excited about about everything
that has to do with entaglement okay for
example this the C the this is a very
famous theem we heard about this last
week here in in this journal Club there
something I think somebody will talk
about it even there some kind of a CM
this this can be kind of understood in
terms of anang enthropy so CM means that
if you have a randomization group flow
somehow that that somehow C this
quantity always kind of goes down the
direction of somehow and it happens that
this C is exactly related to uh the
amount of inang entropy in a region okay
so there's there kind of connections
between the nalization group uh angular
enthropy but also somehow between the
realization groups and and and
understanding how States look like and I
will kind of certainly later in this
talk um try to uh Focus uh on this okay
so um so I don't know exactly how far
this will lead to okay I think it's it's
it's so so what is very clear to me is
that that in in in in many branches of
physics and not just physics also
quantum chemistry somehow the um um the
the big bottleneck in the last whatever
for 100 years or almost 100 years has
been described correlations what are
quantum correlations okay what what what
is all of how do you kind of quantify
how do we kind of deal with them okay
what what do you deal with with Beyond
somehow the free fums of course it
happens that that most of the physics or
most of materials can be understood you
don't need this kind of strong
correlations but but the really
interesting materials and interesting
means the things that are not understood
yet so that that's somehow there
challenging uh um um um physical
problems there are exactly all the
materials that have strong correlation
and it looks like like like the theory
of entanglement and uh uh is is
extremely well suited for tackling
problems like this and I think so
certainly people like like like Matthew
Hastings kind of completely Pion this
and show that somehow with this things
you can he comes actually from that
field but
uh okay so
um what um should I talk about uh today
actually umash asked me to just repeat
the talk that I gave here last year okay
that's what uh that's what you not I
think that's what you exactly or update
talk and that's what I will try to do
somehow I will kind of try to repeat a
bit somehow the the lines of thought
that I sketched here last year so I have
to apologize for people that uh already
know everything and for people that
think that everything I'm saying is Thal
so um
um okay so what is the main problem in
uh let's say so so I will mainly Focus
is on Quantum spin systems okay and in
Quantum spin systems you have some kind
of Anoni that is a sum of local terms
and local really remain spatially local
okay it doesn't mean like local in the I
think the the the the biggest mistake uh
that uh or the only mistake probably
that Kai have ever made is to call kind
of hison QA construction local okay
because local in physics really means
spacially local and not it's not because
you have a two body interaction this is
typically not called local okay but this
is a kind of a source of many of of some
confusion so local uh in in physics
really remains typically spin local you
have a Quantum spin system matter in
what dimension typically the um it
happens that the that some of the most
interesting kind of open problems in uh
in condens matter uh actually happen in
two Dimensions okay that's that's
because I will give you some kind of an
an idea why two Dimensions indeed
somehow something where strong
correlations uh are important uh and in
three dimensions typically somehow these
these these these strong correlations
have a less effect this is of course not
entirely true because in Quantum field
Theory strong cor like in Quantum
chromodynamics qcd describing strong
interaction Som it's really a
threedimensional problem that is that is
that's very hard and it's very clear
that strong correlations are relevant so
uh but somehow many of the of the open
problems in met physics at least uh deal
with uh uh with two dimensional systems
but also onedimensional systems actually
the one need somehow the correlations
are even the strongest okay because they
have the least uh amount of uh
frustration Okay so so you have like a
motor these are like nearest neighbor
okay so you have some kind of a coupling
between this one and this one maybe next
nearest neighbor uh typically these are
kind of uh of uh decaying um uh using
leoson bonds you can actually kind of
come up with a pretty kind of good
definition what locality means okay so
if you like look at at uh uh the com
such that there is a Le in velocity okay
this uh is a kind of a very reasonable
way of of of of defining what is does it
mean what is
what what does it mean for for h to be
local and actually all the most of the
results that are known are exactly kind
of uh or or most of the rigorous results
about ground States and entanglement and
things like that is exactly for H TOS
that satisfy this condition for having
any problems in B problem basically
means that that if you have a signal
signal can only propagate with a certain
speed through the uh through the through
the lce okay so this Hon doesn't allow
you for something like super luminal
communication and that's that's
basically what these conditions uh uh
mean now so typically in many cases this
hamiltonian describes the electronic
degrees of freedom okay so what you have
is like you have atoms so these are
atoms and around these atoms you have
kind of electrons and most of the
electrons are tightly bound to that atom
okay so that means like like just uh
like the sand the P band all these kind
of low level things they they are very
because somehow the charge of that
nucleus is so large somehow they're very
very closely bound and the kind of
degrees of freedom you can basically
ignore okay so there's no so it's only
the outer shells basically the very
outer shells of your atom that somehow
will be delocalized and will allow to
hop and these are the degrees of freedom
that you want to kind of describe okay
that's really where the where the where
the problem comes into into play but it
happens that um uh and this is this is
actually pretty amazing it it happens
that that room temperature for these uh
for typical uh electronic systems is
extremely small okay so typical kind of
energies of of of these electrons that
somehow the energy scale on which they
defined is like in the order of 10,000
Kelvin okay that means that that somehow
room temperature is is really very very
small okay just to just to give you an
example of how small this can be if you
take a hydrogen atom and one electron
you could ask okay so just and let's
assume that you can describe this with a
uh uh with with a bolman distribution so
just okay this is e to the minus beta H
this is actually there's some problems
with this but let's not talk too much
about you could ask okay what is the
probability somehow what is the relative
probability of being in the ground state
versus the first excited
state okay and uh you we result and this
is e to the minus so uh um it's like the
the the Gap in your system is exactly
like 10 electron volt is like the
divided by and and
0.025 of electron volt this is kind of
room temperature this is e to-
400 okay this is an amazing number okay
this is the probability of being in the
excited state the first excited state
versus being in the ground state so just
to give this is like of course in
practice this this this calculation is
not really true because this is not a
thermal State and things like that but
just is to give you an idea of the order
of magnitudes of these kind of of of of
of of our electronic systems you're
really in the ground state okay so the
ground state is really the right thing
to do that's why people canot focus on
ground state so if you have bosonic
systems like uh interacting bosons
actually the picture is uh is is is very
different okay there you really have to
cool and that's why these people that
that have bothos Einstein condensates
and things like that they really have to
make they really have to kind of do an
extremely hard job to to cool that down
to somehow micro or Nano Kelvin and all
these kind of things because because the
situation of of of of of bosonic systems
is very different okay the the reason
why these energies are so high is that
you fill there some kind of a f FY and
you have to fill it and the energies on
top of this FY are kind ofar okay so
this is actually of course a bit
cheating this this is this is in Comm
metaphysics it's not that extreme okay
it's it's not not eus 400 but it's still
kind of typically a large number and
that's why people care about uh about
just describing ground States because
systems are typically in uh the uh the
the ground state okay so um so what
happens now is that let's let's focus on
Hon translation variant so that this
kind of thing does not depend on where
it is okay so we have the same ter
between these two and these two or these
two fation and and and and transational
uh invariance so so it's clear we want
to be um in the in in in in the ground
state uh so what does that mean is that
so what is the energy of a state so I
have the state so what is the energy of
a state that or the energy density okay
of a state that uh uh with respect to
this Hon is
obviously just take one term out one two
s this is the energy density because you
have to multiply this with uh with n and
this is equal to trace row one2 * h12
okay this is kind of the trivial thing
this is the reduced sensity Matrix uh
with respect to these two sides let's
say this is 1 2 * h12 so this is the
energy and it's very clear that if
you're in the ground state this is the
quantity you minimize okay so you want
to minimize but to have minimal energy
that means that you must have an extreme
point in row okay so the reduced density
Matrix the local reduced density Matrix
must be an extreme point in some set
okay and at the end we'll see that
indeed all the physics about finding
grounds it's uh it all follows basically
from characterizing extreme points of
this convex set of local reduced T matri
okay so in principle this problem is
trival we know exactly what the
conditions are okay this reduced T
matric just has to be positive any kind
of reduced Anri are positive there
exists a state a purification for which
it will give you that that that will
give you this okay so so just take for
example the Heisenberg Honan the
Heisenberg Honan would be something like
uh let me write it in qbit language is
something like this 2 two okay and um so
what this has it has three IG vectors uh
with I value plus one and it has one IG
value with uh I value
minus three and this is the singlet okay
so you just work it out and you see that
the ground state of that thing is
actually 0 1 - 1 0 properly
normalized okay that's clearly the
ground state of something like a so so
so now you're assuming you're looking at
an infinite system and you're saying
it's this the ground stated translation
well indeed that's that's of course the
whole point that's where I want to go to
okay so this is so if you would only
have a system that consists of two spins
then this would be the ground state okay
and the ground state would be so so why
why is it that people always talk about
about about about high LS because I
think there's many people in the
audience that don't well really have
kind of looked looked at this this is
really because somehow if you would do
this calculation you have these atoms
these electrons circling around it and
so further and you're exactly at half
filling that means that somehow the
number of electrons is that that is kind
of can hop is equal to the number of
atoms and the interactions are very
strong and in some limit you get exactly
this okay so this is it's really kind of
physically you you get you get somehow
this honess by by by doing perturbation
here or somehow by looking basically at
the low energy sector of that full
through physical H you would get things
like this of course there's lots of
quite a few approximations and the
physics to prove that to go from a
physical thing to this is very similar
to actually what people describe as
gadgets and all this it's it's a very
similar construction yes that again what
was the reason I
didn't okay so so so so the Heisenberg
model is some kind of a limit but I
don't yeah um is is is so if you have
this system here of atoms and there's
electrons circling around it okay so
what happens is that
um you can you can make obstruction you
can kind of make abstraction of of of of
of of most of degrees of freedom and and
the only kind of thing that's really
relevant is there an electron here or is
there no electron okay electrons can hop
and in second quantization this would
mean that for example I go um so what is
you get hamiltonian terms that look like
this plus Herm Mission conjugate what
does it mean is that uh I destroy an
electron here and I create it there this
is what this kind of not means uh and of
course the the complex conjugate and you
also have like terms that with with with
interactions and if you so that means
that if you have two electrons on this
side they kind of strongly repel each
other okay and if you take the limit of
these kind of terms like like this this
interaction very very strong and the
number of electrons exactly equal to the
number of sides uh and you kind of do
the right perturbation Theory so the
generate perturbation you know you first
assume that there's no hopping and only
one electron per side and then then
somehow you add somehow This this term
you do the generate perturbation you
would exactly end up with a hon like
this okay so there there's lots of most
of these H are are pretty physical okay
so so yeah is that yeah that's great
okay okay
so so what you get is somehow uh so this
is a typical hoton hoton so what this
tells you is that the ground state
should be such that you have signets
everywhere okay that's because the
ground state of that viable term is a
singlet so if you would have somehow
yeah so that that's that's the end what
you want okay so the ground of this is a
singlet so what you want to have is a
singet there and a singlet there of
course and a singet there and singet
there and this would kind of minimize
the energy and the energy density would
be minus
three okay but now of course
um what kicks in is this monogamy of
entanglement okay so it is not possible
if you have a spin one half system to
have a singlet here and a singlet there
okay singlet one one spin one half
cannot can of be both maximum Tangled
with two different things two different
spins okay this is uh so um so so Bara
you wrote a paper on monogamy
of so who introduced that term actually
is it no I think that's was a paper
written for when Charlie Bennett
turns and so this he used this term in
his talks about
entanglement so therefore and then I you
know wrote something about his and his
influence on the B information
theory that was the first time I think
it was explicitly
used so so it's very clear that this
monogamy is very important here okay so
you want to have you want to minimize
the energy okay so you want to be as
close to a singlet everywhere but
nevertheless somehow this is impossible
okay because you can you can't share it
so what what is what will nature do do
and actually all the all the physics
like long range correlations power lowc
of Corr all of this somehow the the
nonlocal physics really kind of
originates from this kind of tension
between I want my system to be
translation in variant okay and
nevertheless somehow um uh it must be as
close to it must have maximum local
correlations okay that's that's clearly
somehow the only kind of case where this
is not where there's no kind of of of of
tension there is when when your is
sticky load just a one side thing from
the moment you have like two body terms
there will typically always be somehow
some well that that's always somehow
like a question of monogamy so why do I
say that actually the state has to be
transition variant this is a very simple
result that uh in linear algebra that if
you haveon with certain symmetries then
um there's always uh one igen vector
namely the extremal I vectors always
kind of of of inherit the symmetries of
your uh honia okay of your Matrix um
it's exactly it's a bit it's a tiny bit
more than that because it would could be
that you have symmetry breaking that
means that actually there's no no pure
state with that's that's typically
somehow there's also states that are
ground that do not have the Symmetry but
then there's also always other states
that have the Symmetry and then you can
take the mixture of them and this the
mixture would have the symmetry so it's
not guaranteed actually that there's a
pure state that has the same symmetries
as your homoni but there's always a
mixed state that has it okay so this is
this is what this is why we know that
actually there's this these two things
that uh that uh Happ okay so the whole
problem sorry so you're saying in the
case that there's a ground space there's
always a mixture which
is but if it's a unique Grand state it
must have exactly if it's Unique ground
state it must have all the symmetries of
your honin so if your honin is a C2 then
but it's it's very simple know the the
reasoning is that if I have a hiltonium
and it has a
symmetry this is H then of course H *
si0 si0 this is the ground state should
oh obviously be equal to si0 U dagger H
u0 therefore they should also be a
ground state okay and and if it's Unique
that means that somehow for any kind of
unit you must kind of have that must of
course it's a bit more subtle if you
have a ground Subspace and it's not
degenerate because then this simple kind
of reasoning doesn't go through and
that's why you
can okay but um but the important thing
is
that you want to kind of talk about
ground States this is equivalent and
this is actually the whole problem just
characterize this complex set okay and
that's so the reason that I talk to
about this I guess that this is to
computer like this this is pretty
appealing okay because it becomes like a
combinatorial problem it's like it
becomes like the whole problem of
finding ground States and all this is
equivalent to um characterizing the
extreme points of the convex set
generated by translation in systems or
by systems that have some symmetry okay
so you look at States s that have some
symmetry typically the Symmetry that we
are interested in is translation and
variance but but of course you could do
more you could also do S2 and whatever
and you're interested in somehow
characterizing what are the possible
marginals of that state the marginals
just a two body reduced density Matrix
and somehow the extreme points of that
convex set exactly correspond to ground
states of some local H so there's a one
to one correspondence if you have an
extreme point of that convex set then
there must be a hiltonium for which this
is the ground state okay so so uh um um
let me kind of sketch that or let me
kind of try to um uh to uh to maybe give
you um uh an example of uh of where this
comes from or why this uh this this this
is the case so what you have is this
this complex set okay and
actually let's consider I will consider
a hopium that looks like this uh um i x
i x i + 1 + y i y i + 1 + Delta * Z and
I have to apologize for people that have
seen this I think it's um so you look
this is like the heisen back this
exactly like the heisen model but
there's an extra parameter Delta okay
why do we want a parameter because of
course we just don't want a point in
this conx set I want to have one
parameter family of of of extreme points
in that con set um so if this would be
if you would not have this condition of
translation and variance okay so it
happens that this has lots of symmetries
and the reduced density matri can will
be parameterized by something like the
identity divided by four plus some
parameter x x stand for X Plus y Tor y
Plus on parameter Z * Z tensor Z so
these are the PO operators and just
because of the Symmetry because there
rotational symmetry and so further you
you can be sure that the reduced density
Matrix of ground state can be written in
that form two parameters the small X and
small Z are the parameters and these are
the PO matrices what you can start doing
is now plot also so I just kind of take
this as the xaxis this as the
z-axis um actually I think I did it and
I plot it's opposite this is z and this
is X um and you plot all you do scatter
plot okay I take all states that have um
I I take all possible States okay and
without without I'm posing even that
they have translation in variant and I
do a scatter plot and what I see is that
somehow they all lie with some kind of a
diamond uh a triangle actually this is
the the ground no no I'm not talking
about ground States now I'm just talking
about I'm just doing a scatter
plot of all
possible reduced enity M so all pass
parameters x and z for the reduced enity
Matrix that have the condition that
they're
positive okay so what is the condition
on this on x and z such that row is
positive so this is i l so how is this
related to the
hon well for the moment it's not related
okay but then I will I will I explain it
will explain how it's related okay so
I'm just saying I know that the reduced
TM because of the symmetries must be of
that form okay so let's now just do a
scatter plot let me take any redu Matrix
of that form that is positive and kind
of plot x and z and what you see is that
it has to lie within this
triangle say that you know that theity
Matrix has to be in that form this is
assuming translation VAR no this is
well just take somehow a two- side
hamiltonian then even then it would be
of that form okay that would be a pure
state in that kind of thing okay so all
these these kind of all the extreme
points here are pure States obviously
okay because I'm not I'm not assuming
that translation variance but I want to
kind of show you what happens if you
know in post transation variance how
will it change this convex set okay how
will it obviously it will have to shrink
okay because because there's States like
like this is the
singlet it has kind of maximal
correlation for x and z so this the
singlet is exactly this point as we
already kind of argue this can obviously
not be somehow an extreme point of the
convex set of reduc matrices of
transation variance States okay so how
does this compx set look like um in uh
well it's a bit difficult to draw
because I kind of screw up here try to
see I have to kind of
make first this I will kind of explain
later why this what this means this
diamond so it happens that this convex
set here stick a different
color looks like
this
this this I have to the same here
something like this
compx is it obv that
must because I can always take a mixture
so if I have a state with a certain
reduced Matrix and another one with a
different one I can that that must
exists state that has the mixture of the
reduced so this this set be compx okay
so it happens that all possible redu sty
matrices of translation in variant
systems that have the right symmetries
actually not just they have to write the
symmetries just anything actually you
just look at these components of the
reduced estimat they must lie within
this kind of droplet okay this is like
this is like the way so the way somehow
you oh wait so of course this goes like
this no this is so this is actually just
lying on top of this and then there's
some kind of a strange
blob okay so so let now kind of try to
understand which of these points
correspond to which honi okay
so I have thison so this has this three
parameter Delta okay so it means that
for a given x and z the energy as a
function of Delta is 2 * X+ Delta * Z
okay that's obviously that because the
energy just depends on local
properties okay so let's
know what it means is that you would
like to find so for a given Delta
somehow this determine somehow 2x plus
Delta Z is like this these are kind of
hyper plates sorry iost you can you say
how you how you got this di thing how
you define the set is this the set of
reduced of all trans variant uh States
no no not just I don't require that it's
ground States I just plot any so take
any any transation Val system and plot
and and project it's reduced TX on that
kind of
Subspace okay ignore all the other
components and plot x and z and you a
scatter plot for anything and you get
and you see that everything is inside is
red kind of so this kind of sub space
fits this Honan but may fit also other
honi
have I didn't talk abouton I just say
look the rest to that Ty comes from this
where do you get this restriction well
just because this thing has lots of
symmetries I know that reduced that
symmet will be of that type but this is
not NE at the end this is not necessary
you just take any stage and kind of plot
the X X Plus y expectation value of this
and pl the expectation value of this and
you will see that it lies in that for
any state that doesn't even have the
same symmetry I that doesn't that
doesn't have to be rotation inv Val but
has actually a translation Val must be
translation inv okay that's so that's a
convex set okay and what I want to kind
of what happens is that the extreme
points of that convex set correspond to
ground states of local Honus and it's an
if and only if okay so to be a ground
state the reduced Matrix must be an
extreme point and vice versa if it's an
extreme point it is actually a ground
state sorry and and you're saying it
would even further if you impose
rotation no um impose for example that
it's a redax of a two dimensional hamon
okay so just take this thing this hamoni
but on a two dimensional grid what you
will see is that this convex set looks
like this
now okay it could go further
threedimensional okay what you see is
that looks like
this it actually shrinks very very quick
okay you could continue playing this
game and you see that in infinite
Dimensions actually you would exactly
recover this
diamond now what happens is what this
diamond is these are exactly the
separable states these are the states
that are kind of separable therefore
have no entanglement whatsoever and
therefore there's no monogamy okay
because they're separable and therefore
somehow it doesn't you don't need
anything so you see that this kind of
reproduces is very nice because plot
these compx set and they kind of shrink
a lot and in infinite Dimensions you see
that actually you don't need a Tang at
all and that's actually the
justification why people in physics
always say in high Dimensions meanfield
theory is exact okay this is really this
is the the kind of this comes from this
kind of picture that in in that
separable states and need some the only
states that are compatible with the
symmetries are actually the the
separable states
yes how does symmetry breaking work I
will explain that okay so um symmetry
breaking actually corresponds to
faces okay so what we will have is um
that's actually a good question but let
me let me and if I don't talk about it
ask me later okay because
uh
yes the curves one two Dimension you
know exactly the other yes so the the
One D so actually this uh this red one
you can reproduce exactly because it
happens that the ground state energy of
that thing is exactly known and this is
by the given by the beta ons and that's
how you but let me and so let me kind of
show you how I kind of came up with this
plot okay so for for
the and you will understand then why
somehow the yeah why ground States
correspond to extreme point so so for
the for this particular model this
particular model in one dimension is is
integrable okay there there's something
like a beta on and therefore you know
there there's kind of a a way of exactly
knowing what the ground state energy is
of that hon as a function of Delta okay
so you just plot e of Delta 2x plus
Delta Z this kind of gives rise to a
hyper plane okay so let's draw this kind
of thing so for a given Delta for
example Delta is equal to uh uh to one
okay for or minus one I'm not too sure I
have to have to think about it you draw
this okay and you draw exactly this this
a function of x and z so it gives you a
hyper plane okay hyper plane and you
draw this and you get exactly this
curve okay you change a little bit your
parameter Delta you get a new energy and
again plot this hyper plane you get is
this this this
curve okay you change Delta let and you
get this thing and you see that indeed
somehow this convex set is exactly
somehow the envelope that you get by
taking this kind of thing for all Deltas
it's the it's the it's the inside and
why is it it's because of course for any
physical state that you can
imagine this must be smaller than this
okay so indeed somehow every
hiltonium gives you a it cuts your kind
of plane into two pieces it tells you
for any state because it's a ground
state the energy must be larger and
therefore somehow has to be on the right
hand side of it can you plot somehow all
these uh kind of hyperplanes and somehow
the convex hle of all these things is
exactly kind of thing so by just knowing
this you actually don't know what x and
z is no it's not enough if you know the
energy then you still there's not enough
information to kind of deduce actually
what the ground state is okay because it
like could lie anywhere on that curve
but then by changing a bit your
hamiltonian and by kind of turning it
around you kind of see that indeed it
must be the intersection between them
and okay
so um it happens like in this 2D case
let me give you kind of a uh that
there's some kind of something strange
happening here you have here a point
then you have a face and then here you
have like this thing going on okay so
what does that mean this actually
corresponds to A first order phase
transition okay so actually there's lots
of physics that you can deduce from this
I don't I really don't know why people
matter have not kind of looked at these
kind of diagrams okay because you can
can actually reduce lots of physics like
syy breaking I I don't I didn't forget
your face okay so let's so it happens
that there's a there's a face in this
really a flat piece okay so why does
that correspond to a first or face
transition is because somehow you have
your Honan okay you you kind of change
your angle Delta and suddenly somehow
there's of course there's some kind of
an angle here and suddenly you will jump
from here from that point to that point
by an infin asmal change of Delta if you
have a flat piece from well can this you
have a flat piece this is a convex set
so you kind of you have your aonan you
have Delta here and somehow you stay at
that point if you change Delta and
suddenly somehow when you're when the
angle of your Delta corresponds to that
flat piece you will jump from that point
to that point okay because next next
time some you turn a little bit further
you end up in this kind of Point okay
this is want St first all so these are
these are uh first order uh face
Transitions okay so uh another kind of
example is what happens if you have
simply breaking okay so this means that
like here I only ploted x and z these
are like the symmetries of my
hamiltonian so in principle there should
be nothing more this should be the
reduced anity Matrix but what happens in
physics is actually that in the teric
limit that could be that you get some
kind of an a parameter that emerges that
should not be there okay so like like uh
even if the in the icing model the
classical iing model somehow there is
principle theing model is kind of
completely invariant under kind of
changing all spins up to spins down so
you should not have magnetization and
nevertheless the temperature is low
enough you have a magnetization okay
what this this corresponds to in this
picture it means that somehow you have
an extra parameter here like your order
parameter and in the Symmetry broken
face you would have
like a flat face okay this would
correspond to a face that's completely
flat here okay so that means that indeed
there are St
that have a non-rival expectation value
for this parameter that have the same
energy as the one with all the
symmetries okay that's why somehow you
have symmetry breaking this is a
completely flat thing and somehow and
you can even deduce somehow what the
critical exponents are okay because you
you look at close to a phas transition
somehow there's no and on one side there
is we no face because we don't have
symmetry breaking so there is no kind of
pH on that kind of P thison set and
suddenly at the phase transition there's
kind of a phase emerging okay and the
speed at which somehow this flat kind of
piece in this extra Direction kind of
the the the the let's say the the length
of that thing is exactly proportional to
the critical exponents and all these
kind of things so we can really reduce
the physics uh from this can you
generate weird d by changing the form
ofon such that flat faces intersect flat
faces sure sure but this is the ex this
is flat you know and this is flat right
but so then you won so then what will
happen if you if you go this direction
well kind of continue here and somehow
at some point you you end up here and
you change Delta and nothing changes
this is like the pherom magnetic point
you just keep on pher magnetic and you
kind of change Delta nothing changes
it's still the same ground the ground is
independent of this Delta and suddenly
if you kind of this is well of course
going from this to this is like you have
to change the signs also of the X and Y
so you need extra parameters actually so
I was a bit cheating somehow I should
introduce an extra parameter here like J
* this plus Delta time this because
otherwise I would only have one site of
those but anyway so you kind of turn and
then suddenly somebody will jump from
here to that
point so you P this also first order
first
well yeah but but somehow to go from
from this thing to this this this this
this has to change from plus infinity to
minus infinity or something like that
this is there's inde need some kind of
non I'm not I I would have to this is we
have to think about how to to do this
but but inde so so the message is that
you have have like a convex set and you
can read off the whole phas diagram by
looking at that convex set all the
physics like what is the order parameter
all these kind of things you immediately
see it basically by looking at at at at
that convex set and especially where the
faces are on that convex set okay the
flat the faes correspond
to mention as
you separable states that that justify
field approximation could you have
classical correlations still
you could be losing you could be going
to separable States but still have
physical
locality yeah yeah but um I think inde
these kind of points they have actually
correlation because otherwise somehow
this expectation values would be zero so
the one that is but uh but but but but
it's like kind of the correlation if
this spin up then that one is also spin
up so this is like this is the type of
correlations you have okay so that's not
really me field so I'm
quite
well but of course there actually mean
field is again one of these words
there's many in different kind of in
physics that means something different
some people kind of call Heart ref
theory mean field okay well this is kind
of inde mean field in kind of free Fons
but but it's not from from this point of
view what I drawing here this would be
very far from non mean field okay so so
so like like so what I say is mean field
here is that your on is such that your
reduced tens Matrix you're kind of so
that you can appro Pro imate so it would
really there would be a product state so
there's really a product state that
would kind of have the same energy as
the exact ground
state okay or at least the same
extensive so this is about so all of
this so all what I'm drawing here is of
course about extensive quantities okay
this is the energy density okay and
that's um that's one of
the uh one of the the the I think the
real challenges for this whole field in
uh in in Quantum hilon complexity is
indeed to kind
of understand what the complexity is of
reproducing local quantities okay so so
so so um what are the conditions such
that like like for for 1D Gap systems
okay of course you will need conditions
like a gap okay maybe kind of
characterizing this convex set for 1D
Gap systems is actually a b okay in the
sense that somehow this is even for a
system that is infinitely long okay this
because that's what we are talking about
here we are talking about systems that
are translation variant and actually n
is equal to Infinity it might still be
possible to kind of uh characterize or
uh the somehow the local properties okay
in a u in an efficient way okay so what
is the complexity of uh uh of of of of
of of doing this this is actually not uh
but the Gap doesn't at all show up here
no no there's no no no of course just no
no just so yeah the only but I think
it's a kind of a a a nice picture of
understanding somehow what what what
what hon have to do with local and
somehow how to how to how to get so so
that's there's one I mean it's can I say
one more thing I mean I think it's a
nice concise way for presenting it but
of course you don't it's not like okay
my question is what new thing if you
already know the system you know the
boundary the faces you can re represent
it in this way but does this
representation also give you a way of
getting at those you know where that R
line goes right is that's what exactly
so this is this is this of course what
we doing so so the thing that we are
doing in with all these tensor networks
and things like that is approximating
this convex set from from the inside
from the inside so you try to kind of
come up with with methods of
approximating this and proving that
indeed the distance between somehow the
inner convex set and the outer one is
decaying very fast as a function of the
number of parameters okay so we have
exactly results like this and I think
that's the ones that are possible to
kind of uh that would allow you to prove
this these kind of things are in in but
I don't understand the thing about the
Gap because right there's nothing in
this thing you're just drawing these
Comics up because you're saying you
would expect that for Gap systems you
have this approximated matrix product
sets and somehow you can prove that
that's close to you know really what it
can be but but there's nothing in this
plot that depends on this no no because
it's it's it's a it's just a scatter
plot it's just a scatter
plot
but the challenge is to kind of come up
with methods that approximate that
complex set be it from within or from
without okay there's actually lots of
work also being done by people in
chemistry to approximate such conx sets
from the outside actually with same the
Gap just an additional condition on the
density me no but but the thing is given
somehow given that you have a gap okay
you would like to make claims that
indeed these extreme points Som how you
can kind of no given that you have a gap
you want a reduced set right you you're
saying you get this set with the red
thing from the translation symmetry
right and the monogamy yes somehow you
want to say if I have a gap I get
something that is even uh exactly so so
so so the kind of line of thought is
that if you have a gap then we know that
matrix product States kind of are good
representations but for the moment
somehow the the the the cost the
computational cost is still Pol
polinomial in this and the number of
sites Okay so so what I would like to go
to is making claims that I can actually
approximate this convex set when n goes
to Infinity in polinomial
time okay so this is this is this is not
implied At All by these kind of results
and this is because in physics at the
end you're mainly interested in need I
not main need somehow I think these are
great results of course this this this
this proof of area L that this is in p
and things like that but but at the end
what you what what the physical
quantities are all extensive quantities
okay quantities indeed that have to do
with this and so what does the gap how
does the gap show up the Gap has to do
with actually what is the density of
States close to this thing okay if you
would plot somehow how many states what
is the density of States close to Des
border okay if it's gapped then this
will be much much less than if it's Gap
less okay it's like you would just not
look at what what happens here this is
how we would be able to see but let me
give you one possible result okay let me
kind of give you so so at the end what I
want to what I would love to see and I'm
sure that somehow people in in in uh in
in computer science have the that the
tools to to to prove this but let me
kind of give you one small example so in
like in one dimension I think it should
be possible to kind of prove what the
complexity is of kind of getting this
exact complex set what's the parameter
in your polom if the system is going to
yes that's what I that's so so uh like
take a one dimensional system and um cut
it into two pieces okay so I have it
into two pieces and assume that your
smidth values are given by LDA I
okay so the result uh that we have is
the following the defined Epsilon of D
is equal to the sum I is equal to D + 1
to Infinity of Lambda I these are
actually the Schmid coefficients Square
now these are the I values of redu
stanity Matrix okay so this is kind of
the number this very similar kind of
quantities as you have in all these
proofs of of of one are and that this is
the number this is the weight of the
Schmid
coefficients of the all of the of the of
the very small ones okay so furthermore
you define something like a new quantity
gamma D is something like a sum Alpha is
1 to D sare root so this is the square
root three of the T times the sum beta
is 1 to D Su n is = 1 to Infinity of
Lambda beta + D * n so it's very it's
pretty technical okay but just to give
you a
flavor okay so Define these kind of two
quantities these two quantities they
scale very similarly they both have to
do with the weight of your Tails okay
what you can prove is that if um that
that all local reduced operators okay so
not just so all quantities not just like
the energy but also the magnetization
all possible somehow that the the the
trace distance between somehow Sigma and
the one that you get by cutting so so so
obviously this is a kind of a state and
you can make a matrix product State out
of it by cutting away all these small
Schmid coefficient and you do it not
just here but you cut away the Schmid
coefficients everywhere and now we would
like to make claims that by cutting
these things away I don't change much my
reduced anity Matrix and therefore I can
approximate somehow this convex set okay
so what the result is that this is
smaller than 1 / d^2 with d the local
Dimension time 2 * the root of Epsilon
of D plus Epsilon of D plus this gamma
of
D this see that indeed somehow if your
Schmid coefficients are decaying fast
enough and I think actually there are
very clear tools to do that because
that's what what kind of has been proven
and in this kind of proes of area lws
then you can show that inde reduced T
Matrix but can be approximated now you
see that this is really in the teric
limit this is really about every local
quantity okay so this means that the
approximating this convex set should be
in P but you you need very strong you
need pretty strong bounds on this smid
because there are square roots here okay
you basically sum up all these things
with uh with uh with with square roots
and um yes but so you want to have these
local density Matrix up to an error
Epsilon which is just a small constant
yes right and yeah whereas this you know
the more demanding would be that epon is
one over po n and so on but but let me
show that for example if you
um that's more what what is this let's
let's take let's take actually exactly
this system here okay this XX xxz model
as a function of Delta then actually in
that particular
case we know exactly what this Epson D
is okay so you have to define something
like a parameter Z is equal to the
exponential of minus 2 AR cosine
hyperbolic of Delta okay so this is
something that is smaller than one this
parameter z um and then it happens that
this Epsilon of D is kind of scal for
large D as an
exponential ofus 3 * log Z / pi^
2times the log of D
squar okay so so you see that actually
the scaling so this error decays faster
than any
polinomial this okay so it's an
exponential of log d s that's that's
actually the only thing that matters
exponential minus log d^2 okay so it
means that indeed somehow this this
Decay is faster than any polinomial and
therefore you can kind of start making
claims of how difficult it is to uh um
to to to approximate this but of course
this is kind of the way we derived this
is is very kind of arch this is
something to result that we did together
with gasio uh in in a paper that nobody
read from
2006 so this talk this these results are
are there and you see that indeed
somehow there is super Pol normal
scaling so there's really some kind of a
hope that you can
that that that there all kind of
algorithms in P to approximate the
set and the question is how does my
resources scale as a function of the
error that I want to make okay and this
is exactly what this SC second scale
this GMA D well this scales very
similarly but I don't think we even have
worked it out because was too much but
was like it's it's lots of comics and
things like that for even for that
particular example of the xxc model but
uh what we are sure of is that there's
much better ways of doing that and I
think this would be um very nice to uh
uh to achieve because this would this
would really kind of show that that that
the somehow the energy all the all the
extensive quantities can be kind of
approximated efficiently using whatever
me of course you of course this doesn't
kind of prove that this n p you still
have to find basically what this Matrix
produ state is it just proves that that
exists a matrix produ state that kind of
allows you to kind of approximate this
compx set to position you still have to
prove that you can find it and that's uh
that's a
um so just um we are now cutting into
bre which okay I will stop I will stop
so uh
so well no I think I think so what I
actually wanted to talk about is uh uh
is the work uh recent very recent
we together mainly uto Hagan was kind of
the um with uto about um about really
doing physics so so so what I wanted to
talk about but I is is that is that
actually this formalism is a kind of a
good justification of of looking at
tenser networks that tens networks are
like the perfect kind of um uh states
that that that have both of these
properties they have the translation
variance built in and they also have
very strong local correlations okay that
this is like this if you would think
about it and you think hard enough about
it you would end up with these Mex
product States or or peps and things
like that and um so the whole so
together somehow mainly together with
ignas Sak and and Norbert and and a few
other people somehow
we are really trying to rephrase the
whole of con matter physics within this
kind of new language of of of uh um of
of entanglement okay in terms of so and
the great thing is that that that
somehow you recover some kind of a local
properties like like what topological
order in these kind of new ways in these
tensor networks becomes kind of nothing
more than a symmetry of your tensor okay
so so instead of global things somehow
everything becomes local anymore you
kind of end up with local kind of of of
of of of ways of characterizing kind of
nonlocal uh properties so so what uh uh
what with UT what we mainly have been
doing is trying to understand what
happens so so what what this manifold
looks like all these states these St
Network States or these matrix product
States they form kind of a manifold so
what happens if you kind of do the
physics on these manifolds so instead of
working on a on on on a hbert space or
or with a sh equation that is linear and
an exponentially large space let's work
with some nonlinear differential
equations on that manifold okay what
what can we do what can we learn from
from this uh and indeed this is you can
kind of understand all these matx for
states in this language what are
excitations okay what what are kind of
not just the lowest energy states but
what are the elementary excitations okay
these Elementary excitations you can
really prove things them you can prove
that they are kind of particle like and
you can start looking at how they
scatter each other and how they so
there's like a whole body of physics
that people that that can be rephrased
within this whole language and it's a
very long-term program that that we want
to do and it's uh I think there's lots
of facets uh to it not just the facets
maybe they should have called these
facets but uh um not not just numerical
but mainly also theoretical there's like
a whole kind of there's lots of kind of
new things that you can do within this
uh this one you can also look at Quantum
field theories you can look at at uh
yeah many things so how the goal is to
do physics from this new point of view
from this enagement point of view and uh
and that's very exciting because we have
to learn new things every day
thanks
what's a good reference for this xxz
work you're talking about well the the
the title of the paper is called matrix
product States represent ground States
Faithfully yes so that's also in
it that's
a
yes more
questions okay so we should can after
the
good
thanks